Hôm Thông Mi đu nó trăm nhận đệnh chính sức mạnh nè, rất là cường vũ trang uống khuay nè và cơ quan an ninh uống khuay nè
phối hợp thực hiện không một một thằng sau, chúng đó tấn công các cân cứ cân cú không quân nè và làm nơi hại hàng chục mấy bay,
đã khiến mắt sự gà và có lý sau để phản công.
Ngay sau đó, ngà đã phát động đưa tấn công bằng tên lừa và uả vê khuay mô lớn và thủ đồ kếp
và các khu bực miền tầy uống khuay nè khi niết nhất bốn người thịt mạng và tạm mới người bị thương.
Tổng thống khuay nè vô lưu đi mẹ cho lần chờ biệt, đây là một trong những đột tấn công giữ giống nhất kể từ đầu xung đột.
Fíng a tuyên bố các một tiêu bao gồm cơ sẵn yên cứu, sẵn hấp giác của WV,
khó bố khí và trung tâm vợ luyện quân sự.
Chè lấy báo chiến như một sau tận xấu tổng thân trang nói,
hành động gố khuay nè đã cho tổng thống phu chiến khai cơ,
để vào cuộc và nếm bông giữ giội vò hợp.
Ông bố v xuống đột nha ở quên nha như một trận ở đả cân thư giám tự kết thúc.
Chờ thấy sự thay đổi só dài trung lập trường của ông về giải pháp trấm rất trình trang.